[Musique]
le ch'ti dhr cette boisson alcoolisée à
base de pommes est de plus en plus
populaire au coeur de la ville dans ce
bar du boulevard saint-laurent le cidre
cool des fûts c'est tout ce que tous les
filles on en revenait au sentiment que
l'offre décideront fut a triplé depuis
l'ouverture il ya quatre ans et c'est
sans compter tout le choix de cidre en
bouteille il ya beaucoup plus d'eau
viavoo plus des différences y au
renouveau une énergie qui se passe dans
le cidre un mouvement que l'on a vu dans
les micro brasseries ya 20 ans c'est un
produit qui était méconnu au québec puis
on est tombé en amour avec ça on n'est
pas certains posteurs juste avant
l'ouverture
nous on aime travailler avec des
producteurs la petite échelle humaine et
50 ans d'interdiction de vente en raison
d'un oubli dans la loi lors de la
création de la commission des liqueurs
le porte-parole yvon deschamps encourage
à consommer le cidre du québec qui nous
fait mal quand le gouvernement bourassa
décidé en 1970 de permettre à nouveau la
vente de cidre il ya des permis ont été
émis puis à des gens qui ont fait un
petit peu de sortes d'affaires
approximatif il ya des gens qui n'ont
qu'un gardé des mauvais souvenirs mais
si on parle à des gens plus jeunes ils
ont pas se référer stéphane morin est
historien et auteur d'un guide sur le
cidre au québec
l'agenais s'intéresse beaucoup au cidre
surtout parce que c'est un produit qui
facile à consommer une accessibilité au
niveau du palais pour le vin pour la
bière faut avoir quand même un certain
apprentissage
pour encore plus d'accessibilité il y a
aussi les produits prêt-à-boire en
canette qui se multiplient sur les
tablettes pétillant effervescents
francky et le rosé aromatisés les cèdres
s'éclate
il peut être difficile de s'y retrouver
la seule appellation qui existe c'est
l'appellation pour le cidre de glace
donc pour laquelle un comité d'agrément
puis un cahier de charges et à une
énorme qu'il faut respecter et la
législation est très ancré dans le passé
et les descriptions les catégories ne
reflètent peut-être pas ce qu'on
retrouve sur la marché faut apporter
cette connaissance là auprès du
consommateur puis il expliqué qu' il ya
des différences dans les types de portes
qui vont des jupes moins distincts que
les gens qui vont faire des assemblages
aujourd'hui est une et frédéric de la
cidrerie chemin 17 fonds de
l'échantillonnage
il goûte lycée de rentrer poser dans les
barriques de chêne l'idée c'est de créer
des assemblages de 5,6 barriques pour
trouver une belle complexité à bel
équilibre une barrique va avoir un rendu
plus acier d'une autre va avoir une
belle texture une autre la pomme est
très présente donc l'idée c'est d'aller
trouver ce mélange de saveurs pour que
dans la bouteille au final on a quelque
chose de bien équilibré et une issue qui
a fait beaucoup
qu'est ce que vous dites et tient de sa
goutte le café voyons un de nos aussi
s'appelle turbo pêcheurs on travaille
dans les fûts de chêne américain qui a
promis lyon 7 rebonds des états unis
dans les distilleries oui ça se retrouve
ainsi subtilement la peau mais toujours
en avant mais en petites notes subtiles
et à la fin on recherchait le café les
terrifier un peu le bourg blanc cuillère
puis de vue quand on a parti chama 17 il
était difficilement concevable pour moi
de pas avoir des barriques autour de moi
je n'ai jamais utilisé que ça
chacun est son savoir-faire sa méthode
et le principe est simple le jus de
pomme pressé et fermenter et le sucre de
la pomme se transforment en alcool avec
poussant les bulles on félicite de
fermentation spontanée du conte suis là
lover qui présente naturellement sur les
fruits tout le processus de fermentation
se fait en fût de chêne une fermentation
maturation en garde nos sites sont très
secs un cidre sexe et que presque tout
le sucre de la pomme est transformé en
alcool le taux d'alcool d'un cidre peut
varier de 2 à 15 % et la variété de
pommes influence le groupe au québec les
variétés traditionnelles telles qu'on
les connaît bon macintosh empire spartan
colt cloud ses dépens qu'il nous
fournisse beaucoup d'acidité puis un bon
sucre mais il ya un élément marocaine à
la pomme au québec en général si l'état
main dans la pluie ou l'amertume
on arrive à trouver un angle pour rendre
ces pommes le intéressant maire nous de
notre côté on est à la recherche de ta
main de structures d'amertume alors on
entre dans vos champs expérimentaux
oui tout à fait donc super celle de
pamiers qu'on implante et que son pot et
évaluation caroline provost mène un
projet de recherche pour développer des
variétés de pommes spécifique au cidre
comme ça se fait ailleurs dans le monde
celle ci c'en est une variété de formats
site donc on voit le vrai mais ça peut
ressembler à une pomme à croquer
quand on veut évaluer des variétés bons
doivent regarder le voile et
agronomiques donc comment un processus
dans les conditions du québec comme
elles se comportent les variétés de
pommes à cidre demande beaucoup moins de
traitements phytosanitaires qu'une pomme
à croquer donc moins de pesticides
finalement de résidus possible tout à
fait c'est pas la même chose qu'on va
rechercher dans une pomme à croquer ou
vraiment l'apparence vos primes est
d'abord quel est l'avantagé d'utiliser
une pomme à cidre quand on produit un
cidre la pomme doit être capable
d'apporter des tanins des polyphénols
c'est un peu comme les vins et donc on
cherche des arômes on cherche le ko on
lui dit que c'est sa nouvelle embauche
que ça vaille une certaine structure une
complexité
dans son atelier avec le neurologue
richard caroline déguste lycée dreux je
suis étonné par la colère
eux ils produisent des cidres fait à
base d'une seule variété de pommes puis
analysées note le goût la couleur les
arômes et le potentiel de cette pomme
indépendant par celle qu'on a planté dès
la première année
ces composés de la golden reçu un appui
de legault est-ce que c'est très sucré
un cidre choix du producteur il ya moyen
de vouloir conserver un un sucre
résiduel dans le sud puis d'en faire un
super bel équilibre avec c de notre côté
nous on préfère travailler avec avec des
sites qui sont très secs ton absence
totale de ce christ duel qu'il soit sec
ou sucrées pétillant au plat le prix
peut varier selon la catégorie jusqu'à
30 $ pour une bouteille alors que le
verre ou la canette est d'environ 3 à 9
dollars
honnêtement on n'invente rien on
travaille avec les méthodes ancestrales
c'est une créativité une innovation a le
sens où ces petits décide y était très
peu proposé récemment dans le paysage
québécois d'antan
on commence à avoir de plus en plus
c'est innovant dans ce sens le mais
c'est pas nouveau
malgré l'engouement actuel on boit moins
de 400 millilitres de cidre par personne
par année
c'est six fois moins que le reste du
canada un bon si certains vont dire les
cidre breton cd bon cidre et on a
d'autres qui vont dire ben les cidres
tranquille qu'on fait ici au québec
c'est de très bon side aussi donc je
pense c'est selon les goûts
c'est un peu comme les grands 22 villes
à la restauration commencent à réaliser
qu'il est peut-être temps qu'elle met
une carte de cidre sur sa carte de vins
ont eu de la peur un peu d'herbe séchée
un peu de bois
il ya les bhoutanais s'est fait qu il
ait aucune impression de ces embauches
et je pense qu'on rentre dans toute la
mouvance aussi le produit le conte du
québec
son évolution au niveau d'éveil entre
autres cette année on fait quelque chose
qui se fait dans notre cour suivant la
blague que chacun pourrait adopter son
cidriculteurs puis aller le rencontrer
régulièrement parce que la première là
partout autour de nous